Let's next go to Nico from Santa Monica.
Nico, you're on the air.
Hi, David, how are you?
I'm good, thank you.
So I assume you follow either the New York
or The New York Times or Bloomberg vaccine
tracker, correct?
Yes, I do.
I was wondering so that the Johnson and Johnson
vaccine has been approved for use and that
data is not showing up yet.
Are people just not getting the vaccine or
so as of earlier this week, the news so after
the JNJ was approved, but before this week,
when you look at it, I haven't looked at the
Bloomberg tracker for a while, but when you
would look at The New York Times, it would
say Janja has been approved.
We have no data on it.
It's not included in our tracker.
As of this week.
There's a new message on The New York Times
tracker, which says JNJ one dose is now included
here and we are including now because it's
one dose.
If you got the JNJ vaccine, you're being counted
by The New York Times both as having full
vaccination and as having at least one dose.
They're basically double it's not really double
counting.
You're just you're part of both categories.
So my understanding is now JNJ is in The New
York Times tracker.
OK, so so that vaccine data is updated then,
yes, as far as I know.
All right, well, thank you.
All right, Nico from Santa Monica with a very.
Specific question, I guess, is what we would
say, why don't we go next to a go from Florida,
a Mulgoa, you are on the Air Canada.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
All right.
How are you doing?
I'm doing well, so I kind of have a few questions,
but I'm going to start off with this one,
right.
Did you hear about the Nevada Democratic Party,
how basically the establishment just quit
after the Socialists won one percent of the
seats?
I saw a headline about it.
I don't know the details about what's been
going on in the Nevada Democratic Party, but
I did see the headline.
Yeah, yeah.
I just thought it was interesting.
You know, the socialist pretty much took over
and, you know, the the establishment talks
about unity and blah, blah, blah.
And then as soon as, you know, the people
that they weren't really expecting to win
one, they kind of just quit.
And it was just one of those, like, hypocritical
type things like you want to work together,
but when you don't get your way, you just
go away.
That's I didn't like that was just funny to
me.
Yeah, it is.
It is funny.
Based on the headlines I've seen, I plan to
do a deeper dove on it this weekend when I
have some time to to read more stuff about
it.
But I'm curious as to like the background
on it.
I don't know whether this is something that's
been building within the Democratic Party
there for some time or if this like punctually
exploded or what happened.
But it sounds very odd and counterproductive,
to be quite frank.
Yeah.
And then I guess my second question was on
the stimulus package.
You know, you I feel like good Democrats to
do in the twenty twenty two midterms emphasize,
hey, you know, we're trying to pass this bill
and the majority of the GOP, like Republican
voters, are on our side.
Yes.
But yet no Republicans supported it.
So couldn't they use that as a messaging tool
for 20 twenty?
I hope so.
I've been talking about this for a while,
which is if every Republican wants to vote
against something that many Republican voters
actually want there, you would hope that there
are political ramifications to that and you
would imagine that Democrats would figure
out a way to try to hold them to account for
that in twenty, twenty two by running on they
voted no on you getting any money.
Unfortunately, political memories are very
short, and if we're significantly recovered
by twenty, twenty two and Republicans have
fully switched over to the debt, the deficit
council culture, all this stuff, it may just
be too late.
People may have forgotten about it.
Sadly, I hate that that's a reality.
Yeah.
Because I was thinking about it because there's
a new poll that just came out, a YouGov poll,
I believe it shows.
Seventy five percent of Americans want this
bill.
Fifty nine percent of Republicans want it,
but no Republicans voted for it.
So, yeah, they're not representing their constituents
by by definition, literally in a mathematical
sense, they are not doing it.
And for all the flaws Democrats have, I mean,
at least they're trying to get passed because
there's a lot of flaws of the bill.
You know, this is not the minimum wage, more
means testing.
So there's a lot of things that aren't good
about it.
But at least they're trying to get relief
done.
But the right's talking about Dr. Seuss.
So this was my exact commentary, which is
there's a bunch of issues where Democrats
and Republicans aren't very different.
But you look at this, every Republican voted
for people to get nothing.
Democrats, frustratingly, they don't want
the 15 dollar minimum wage.
And remember, it's not like there's there's
Democratic senators who would have voted no
even if you push it into the bill.
That's the that's the frustration they added.
They restricted who gets it.
But but they pass something.
If it were up to Republicans, people would
get zero.
Yeah.
And then my final point is, Tom Cotton, I
think I don't know if you mentioned it.
I don't know who it was.
But Tom Cotton went on FOX News and said,
oh, the Democrats want to give prisoners.
Like, I can't remember who the church guy
was.
I can't remember.
But they want to give him a 14 dollar check
on the Young Turks.
And that same provision was in the Trump stimulus
bill.
But now Tom Cotton hates.
Right.
Trying to do the exact same thing.
Wasn't it like the Boston bomber they were
talking about the Boston bomber?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's insane.
I mean, this is the same thing is when they
say this is a projection of 100000 children
coming across the border, that, well, those
are almost identical numbers to what there
was under Trump.
It's just Fox News wasn't talking about it
then.
Yeah, it it's honestly frustrating.
It's like listening to them.
It's like, listen, Democrats have the flaws,
but at least they're trying to help you guys.
Just complaining, complain.
Did you see a Tim Ryan on the House floor
basically yelling at Republicans like I did?
We're trying to help the workers like you
guys.
Do you complain and complain?
So Tim Ryan's a good guy.
We've had him on the show and I've met him
a couple of times.
Really, really good guy.
Not my favorite, but I know when I was like,
I feel you, man.
No, no, it's not like, you know, he's he's
not inspiring as a progressive leader, but
he's he's relatively progressive and a good
a good guy.
All right, amigo, thank you for the call.
No problem.
Have a good day.
All right.
There is a move to go from Florida or Florida.
I should have asked which of the two he's
from, actually.
Let's go next to.